[Music]  Chris rocks split from his wife in 2014  after 19 years of marriage and now the  comedian is getting candid about his  divorce in Rolling Stone the story  includes bits from rocks stand-up over  the past few months where he tells the  crowd about his own infidelity so after  a bitter divorce would Rock ever put  another ring on it he jokes to the  audience quote not if it would cure AIDS  the star tells the mag his fame played  into the break-up adding quote my faults  are magnified and while Chris says he  never had a breakdown about the split he  admits he cried once during their  custody battle and even bought a house  around the corner from his kids now the  comedian says he's in the middle of  starting over saying after getting  divorced quote you get to reset it's not  a breakdown but something in your life  broke down  [Music]